although sony and marvel studios have
shared custody of tom holland spider-man
so that he can exist in the marvel
cinematic universe alongside the
avengers the former studio is still
pushing ahead with its own universe of
spidey villains and anti-heroes venom
was a surprise hit back in 2018 raking
in 856 million dollars so audiences are
clearly interested in sony's edgy
approach to superheroes it's no surprise
then that the studio is working on a
solo craven the hunter film starring
aaron taylor johnson as well as a madame
web adventure with dakota johnson and
sydney sweeney meanwhile jared leto's
morbius is finally set to arrive in
theaters on april 1st and it's been a
long time coming the movie was
originally intended to debut on july 10
2020 but that was delayed almost
immediately and then the pandemic hit
causing sony to push the release back
several more times morbius follows letto
as dr michael morbius a genius who is
determined to find a cure for the rare
blood disorder that he suffered from
since childhood his research leads him
to an experimental procedure using bats
and it transforms him into a vicious
beast with a comic accurate gray skin
and red eyes enhanced senses super
strength and the ability to fly
unfortunately he also has to contend
with matt smith's luxurious crown and
fbi agent simon stroud played by tyrese
gibson the first reactions from critics
have made their way online and they
paint an interesting picture of sony's
latest marvel movie collider contributor
sab astley blasted the movie for its
poor story tweeting mobius is about as
bad as you were expecting a 2005 plot
collides with visually confusing cgi to
create a bit of a snooze fest but don't
worry they've saved the worst for last
featuring some of the worst post-credits
scenes you've ever seen
sony are off their rocker the we have a
hulk podcast nicola austin echoed the
sentiment noting that it doesn't live up
to the venom corner of sony's marvel
universe she posted well morbius is
unfortunately not great some really
shoddy vfx and 2000s formulaic plot and
definitely not as fun as venom really
confused at the future of the sony
spiderverse following the post credits
scenes and the editing meanwhile escape
film club tweeted that the film's
visuals can't save it posting morbius
proves that no matter how many famous
faces or shiny visuals you squeeze in
sony will always find a way to
impressively misunderstand the basic
storytelling film critic renviera
followed that up writing matt smith
gloriously hams up the place and oliver
wood delivers some visual flair to the
action sequences aside from that the bad
plotting and messy cgi confusing editing
and worse sound mix result in absolute
incoherence but the post credits managed
to outdo it all one of the biggest
questions fans have about morbius is
when is he going to meet the other sony
marvel characters like venom obviously
an earlier trailer reveals a look at
michael keaton's vulture which implies
that a sinister 6 style team-up is on
the way at some point sony has been keen
to make a movie about the squad of
spider-man villains for quite some time
and the original plan was to spin it out
of the amazing spider-man franchise for
the moment it's not clear if or when
morbius will cross over with the likes
of venom vulture or craven although
jared leto previously told screen rants
that all of the marvel characters the
living vampire could meet quote venom
would make a lot of sense that would be
fun it's worth pointing out that just
because the film has had a negative
reaction from critics doesn't mean it
won't be successful at the box office at
the end of the day if morbius is hugely
profitable then sony will likely
continue to use the character in sequels
and crossovers letto himself revealed on
the late late show with james corden
that he could easily cross over into the
upcoming blade movie for now it's
probably best to go into morbius with a
little caution
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]